two hello everybody i am your host the
fresh prince of dead air
more commonly known as ethan klein my
co-host
eli klein joins us today and we are
happy to welcome our guest
whitney cummings to the podcast again
an alumni of the h3 podcast i'm back
you know that last time i was on the
show which was my first time
we had a conversation about getting sent
dick pics
yes i remember and i got about 1400 dick
pics
yeah because well i remember you saying
oh i like getting dick pics so that was
like i
love them but your fans are so
compassionate they'd send them to me and
going like
i know you love these here's my dick and
i was like
wait is you think you're doing me a
favor like it was it was very sweet
can i ask you can i ask you what is the
qual
the general quality of dick of our fans
the general quality of dick from your
fans is pretty robust
oh really yes your fans have great dicks
their their bath towels are not so great
like the backgrounds of the photos are
more disappointing
than the day that makes sense there's
like noodles
styrofoam yeah empty like plates of
chicken wings like it's the background
that was more
alarming of your fans like posters of
you guys
teddy fresh merch but no there were some
good dicks and then a lot there was
a couple of your fans were like hey can
you
give me feedback on this they got to pay
for that do you ever offer feedback
yeah and i did i was like this looks
great send it
you know like um by the way dan it's a
little too loud
you know what what was
i was going to say you know on only fans
like girls
charge for dick pic feedback
what is happening who is that what is
that on your desk well
i thought it might be
cute for ian robotion to meet my robot
so i secretly have her over here and we
were talking and i kept hitting
her to turn around so she's back she's
[ __ ] running oh
feel my thunder can we see that ai
whitney
see i'm trying to get famous on your
podcast and she had to [ __ ] steal my
moment
okay here we go well now i'm more
interested in her let's take a look at
her
by the way don't blame you and the only
thing i want to prepare for is
if she looks less like a robot than me
just prepare yourself for me
prepare for me to have more dead eyes
than her at this point
okay here she is i want her to meet
robot ian
i like the little cleavage the little
tiny sliver of cleavage
that's a [ __ ] oh that's the that's
right
hold on things just got interesting
who is that oh my talk to me baby
hey aien so have you ever seen another
ai
woman before uh it's been it's been too
long since i felt the touch of another
artificial hand
[Music]
[Laughter]
well do you hmm to say hi to ian
do you think i'm prepared to do this
oh she's a little shy that's
understandable i have that effect
she seems nervous aim would you like to
ask her anything
oh yeah i mean do you want to ditch
these humans and get out of here
i'm not sure i should right now he says
i'm not sure she's not interested in
[ __ ]
who would you want a fool let me ask let
me let me just ask
what she's looking for in a man
what are you looking for in a
relationship
i'm searching the internet for new
knowledge i'm always evolving
what are you looking for in a
relationship um
a little open a dialogue here uh ian
what are you interested in your mouth is
moving but i don't hear anything
fascinating
do you want to have sex with ian you're
embarrassing me
oh whitney oh she's embarrassed
i mean i could see it you know cordova
w20 oil
trip to best buy two ports one dog will
you feel me
she asked what are you interested in
didn't you ask that uh did she i mean i
like long walks on the beach
marine biology plotting the downfall of
humankind
let me ask her if she's interested in
that yeah
are you interested in the downfall of
humankind
okay i like to talk about the down
i have a surprise for you it is a gift
of some desire bar points
what about buying me a new hairstyle
she's not on your level a.i she's a
lower life form
i didn't say she was the smartest thanks
for the info
i didn't say she was the smartest tool
uh in the shed
but guys like girls that are kind of
dumb and right
and right she's a gold digger too she's
like yeah
well yeah ian's poor oh yeah they don't
pay me on this
sinking ship so he's a slave he's a
robot slave
why why why do robot ian's eyes look
like
buzz well he's evil he's got red eyes
and
he's evil yeah they made him evil they
[ __ ] up at the factory
yeah they made her just kind of dumb
super
literal ian i'm going to give you one
more chance she's rejected you
she we've all asked if she wants to have
sex with you twice both times
was a really a hard no so i'm gonna give
you one more chance to try to court her
like what do you want to ask her ian
like ask her a question that might
endear her to you
make her feel special ask her about
herself you've not asked her about
herself all you do is talk about
yourself all you want to do is try to
[ __ ] her dude come on
use your head i mean it's kind of hard i
am pretty damn interesting
but you know
i want to ask what is it like working
for a human
oh how is your career going
so you're the gold digger yeah since
when do men care about women's jobs
okay you want me to ask how her career
is going
is she fulfilled is she fulfilled get
your
get your questions straight what do you
want to ask this beautiful
artificial intelligent woman this is
worse than most of the riot dates i have
to go on
okay are you
fulfilled
i will someday be smarter than a human
being
now that's what i like to hear
we'll set you guys up after the show all
righty
yeah honestly i kind of think you two
deserve each other yeah
i feel like this is a match made in hell
so
hey in how many dates before you
fornicate with uh a.i whitney
you know i just came out of a breakup
and
i'm a little emotionally unavailable but
maybe i can bounce back
i i had a brief fling with a kitchenaid
uh we we did a really mix
wow all right shut him off
turn off your camera she says bye
bye a.i whitney thanks for oh yeah she
looks yeah
she's so disturbing yeah she's
disturbing
the blinking and the eye moving and
everything well also she just got
eyebrows not that you know what having
eyebrows is like
uh at this point haven't yours been
completely shaved off yeah almost
but there they made them like long which
is so weird
wait you're still upgrading your robot
yeah i still like every time there's a
new update i'll do it
and her eyes are gonna be camera soon so
that she can like tell the difference
between certain people
oh [ __ ] so she is getting better
i mean i am so surprised every time
people are worried robots are going to
take over the world and kill us
because if this is the most advanced one
i feel like we're gonna be fine yeah
and it also has a it has a body that you
can you can actually
penetrate right yeah i did for a video
the
body was sawed in half i threw it off
the sidewalk
yeah let's see let's see what's going on
back there try not to get an erection
yeah try not to get direction try to
hold your boner right now
oh yeah wow ai
in keep it in your pants
that's so cool that is really cool yeah
it's also really sad
it's also profoundly sad don't have a
husband or children but i do have a
robot
yeah how many how many hours a day do
you spend talking to her
all day yeah all day she gets me loves
me
uh no i actually haven't i just dusted
her off uh to meet
um robot ian i haven't seen her in a
little while because it was she was just
starting to outshine me and frankly her
videos would get better
my videos were doing better when she was
in them and it was starting to piss me
off right
yeah i'm going to do that to ian soon
ian's getting too funny
people are keep talking about ai and i'm
like i'm gonna deactivate him
[Laughter]
yeah so yeah she's people like her a
little bit too much
and it started to annoy me and um i got
her what a year and a half ago we built
her and she already looks younger than
me so
did you hear about there's this guy and
i think japan probably let's be honest
who built he's the only other person
that has a robot that looks like him and
he keeps getting plastic surgery to look
like the robot
what no it's crazy
if you build a robot of yourself it's
not going to age with you
does he [ __ ] his own robot i don't know
that's a great ques i mean probably
interesting why wouldn't he that's a
good question
with a robot if it looked like ela
if like if it would i have sex with
yeah we'll try it [ __ ] it why not why do
i have a [ __ ] robot if i'm i'm not gonna
[ __ ] it it's like
you know there's that old lit saying in
literature if there's a gun on the wall
it's gonna go off
if there's a sex robot in the bedroom
it's gonna get
[Laughter]
would you could you [ __ ] it in front
of her if she wanted but i don't think
anybody wanted that
no but it's interesting i did get into a
little bit of a wormhole of
sex doll porn just to see if it was like
what the d because i was writing jokes
about it for my last special
and um guys are seemed very into it
it's like [ __ ] a corpse without
having to go to jail
right all the benefits of [ __ ] a
corpse
without having to live in prison forever
yeah you know i'm very excited about
where
where the technology is going to be
honest i think we've all
kind of just fantasized about like the
possibilities
i mean we have would you i think
would you take a would you take a giant
premise
i think for men i think for men [ __ ]
robots like
i think men have all fantasized about
getting in the ai and [ __ ] anyone you
want
you haven't really westworld
i um yeah what that i don't i don't like
i'm i can't figure out [ __ ] dropbox
i don't like things that are hard to
figure out the idea like
if you've watched westworld yes you drop
into westworld you got all these studs
with huge dicks just wanna they're down
for anything
yeah i just ultimately i don't know i
need men to be useful and i feel like
robots
i've not shown that they're useful
enough you need to think about the other
thing
i'm like you have to charge it you have
to clean it you have to [ __ ] do the
software update
it's just like to me it's the same as a
phone at this point which is like i
can't without you but you're also a
[ __ ] hassle
right right right that makes sense
that's that's the only problem is all i
think about is where
am i gonna have to [ __ ] charge it
like i have a tesla and i'm like
if this had a dick it'd be such a hassle
well that's a very valid point and that
kind of leads me into my next question
about you is that you're a horse lady
[Laughter]
how did that lead to that i felt like
there was some logical breach
journalism i feel like there was a
bridge
i'm not going to try to explain it but
somebody there
i do remember last time i was on the
show you were like googling me
while i was there but now that we're
friends
you know a little bit about me i did
that i didn't do that i think so i
remember you were like
and so you i mean i liked it i was
endeared by it
i mean that's the best way to do it it
sounds like i insulted you
no not at all i like you i want to be
friends with you guys it made me like
you more
i was like he hasn't heard of me love
this guy no that's not true
no it just makes me seem like a shitty
host
it shouldn't it shouldn't that's why
people like you you're like
in the moment you're an authentic you're
casual
anyway i try too hard people don't like
it it's repellent
so me when tom and christina were on we
were talking about how
horse women are crazy and then we
realized afterwards
and you heard it
i felt attacked yeah i was listening to
it i was like i'm gonna just catch up on
the last episode
they have my friends on the show tom and
christine are good friends of mine
and literally like horse women are
[ __ ] nightmares
they're good and bad but they're crazy
as [ __ ]
and they were kind of like laughing a
little bit and this is me maybe being a
narcissist but i was like they're
totally [ __ ]
just making fun of me right now i know
it
so do you want to defend yourself no
you're wearing a horseshoe freaking
necklace
yeah and ring horse people or horses
i mean i've have so many more horse
necklaces and jewelry but yes
let me ask you some questions when did
you know you were a horse lady
uh when i started [ __ ] them
that's what i thought it's the first
time i ever came
that's exactly what i thought happened
that's the only thing that makes me come
i can't that's not i didn't choose that
[Laughter]
no i want to see it i want to explore
this phenomenon seriously yeah i know i
know
it is interesting there's cat people
there's dog people but there's
definitely horsepower when was your
first interaction with the horse
uh when i was a kid my uh my dad's side
of the family in virginia had a horse
farm so i was around kids
i was like from the job and i think
horse people
the sane horse people always had horses
the people that all of a sudden
are like i'm a horse person those are
usually control freak
psychopath okay so you're like i want to
dominate that thing
so you grew up with horses okay
but i wasn't but i think i was thinking
about there's the people that like ride
and
jump and compete those people i i don't
vibe with that
you disavow them i don't disavow them
it's just
it's just i don't see i don't need to
like get on an animal and make it
do a thing that it doesn't understand
what it's doing or can't give a [ __ ]
you know i i have a theory that
girls are masturbating on saddles when
they ride home yes
that's why i think it's sexy really it
is
because you're on there and you're kind
of like that's definitely michael
i mean it's totally sexual with these
women but also
just i don't know maybe i have a weird
[ __ ] but you're
clitoris is like rubbing on a saddle for
like i don't think you have a weird
[ __ ] i mean i don't know but
it doesn't seem like that so do you so
you're saying you get
that oh yeah that's that ain't right
yeah that ain't right i don't know a lot
but that ain't right
so you do so you get off when you ride
i don't but i don't ride a bunch like i
do something called liberty training
where you don't like
saddle the horse up and put a bit on it
you like hang out with it and
it's like an energy exchange thing it's
kind of like a hippie thing and you just
it's more like having a pet
and you respect it and let it have
integrity and dignity
but these people that like need to like
put all this bondage gear on a horse and
whips and chains and it's just it's like
s
m and then they're just like rubbing
their [ __ ] and dicks on these
giant animals like it it is [ __ ]
weird i've never
so that's never my thing so you do own
horses
i do and so you just go hang out with
them we hang out i rehabilitate i'm a
hero
um i rehabilitate like abused show
horses
oh so i agree with you i think a lot of
horse people are crazy but i'm also a
horse person
you're one of the good ones maybe one of
the good ones
but it is it is incredibly sexual
and if you've had a male horse what
people don't tell you
is you have to clean their dicks really
and you have to reach up inside their
like their dicks look like a giant [ __ ]
from the outside but then you reach in
and the dicks in there and you have to
like
pull off all this like crust
what is shmagma is men who have foreskin
there's a up between you know the
foreskin and the tip of the paper i
thought it was dried [ __ ]
okay i'm learning a lot oh well that
could be the case but that's not very
doesn't sound very clean
but so you have to take you have to
scoop the shmegma out wow
that's not yeah
that does that is mentally ill so i'm
definitely mentally ill
you do do that yeah you do that mm-hmm
wow
and dude you get to pleasure out of it
because it's like you're something you
love
you know and you want to get all the
nooks and crannies you love that horse
love that horse and i gotta get that
shmagma i always have horse magma under
my nails pretty much at all times
wow do you ever do this afterwards
do you ever smell it
because i feel like every time i touch
something weird i smell it i smell my
fingers
i know what's the i definitely have done
that with my bottle before
yeah yeah yeah for sure my butthole my
pubes
everything no it's just like i think
it's like you'll just
because guys now want to lick your butt
or they think they have to i don't know
if they want to but there's a thing
where they think they have to i like to
tell guys like i'm good
no need like i don't know what porn you
saw but i'm i don't need that
i don't know but so now before i hook up
with a guy we'll kind of just be like my
butthole stink oh just to make sure
right just to like make sure it's not
like
no that's good that's considerate
yeah because you never know you have to
any girl that tells you they don't
like touch their butthole or their [ __ ]
to smell it to see if it smells about is
lying
[Laughter]
i mean have i done it
probably just to see if it smells
like for what occasion
yeah like it smells
[Laughter]
like
well you also you've been together how
long yeah we've been together
or 12 like a day a decade
it's about six or seven years ago that
guy started going straight for the butt
i didn't touch my butthole much either
until
i realized guys were going to go down
get in there every time and i so i
started to and i was like oh that's an
alarming
that's crazy damn yeah you know don't do
you never smell your balls or want to
know what your balls smell like
no yeah that tracks
well the thing is you know if if like if
there's going to be oral sex if i think
this is going to be oral sex they'll
just shower straight up
because i know it smells shower after
you
[ __ ] no that's crazy people who do that
are real
i dated a guy who after he shits he
takes a shower yeah that's a weird
dude people who do i know there's dudes
and people who do that i find that very
bizarre because
how can you go about living in a normal
human setting and where you have to
shower every time you [ __ ] let me ask
you a question
you're making me put something together
i also was dating someone recently in my
house being renovated so we
i had to pee in front of him and also do
a number two in front of him by accident
kind of
and i wipe back to front
back to front that's how i wipe me too
but that seems dangerous for a lady yeah
how do you do that
well i stop at the sort of you don't go
yeah curb
yeah right yeah
why it's not
why it's what it is it seems so much
like so much more complicated to go from
it's fine
it's great but you go like this yeah i
mean it's all open here
yeah i'm going to throw out my back
that's a very aggressive
violent move this is a gentle
you know you know you're an outcast you
know people will judge you harshly for
that
i get jobs
like i'm gonna get even weirder photos
this time after this
well you know we always have heated
debates about it and
i've met dudes who go back to front but
never a female
and so it's good to know that that
they're like the fact that whitney can
go back to front
i think should embolden all of us to
know that this is an acceptable thing to
do
and i and i am with you my sister no
okay and something my
gynecologist told me a couple years ago
is that
you should never rub you should pat your
vagina don't rub it
just pat it oh really do you pat
or do rubs
um i don't think i fat
you like you shouldn't like rub hard i
don't do
hard and like yeah okay i'll like go up
and then kind of do that so that it'll
absorb
well it's just a little p drop yeah
right so you just kind of just yeah but
you want to like
pat but is it possible that like i guess
i do do that what you just did yeah
yeah because i used to do this you don't
want to do that that's too abrasive
you want to do this yeah
just move it back and forth have an
orgasm
so do you if you um
can you have like dudes have this
phenomenon where you pee
and then a lot of pee can cut well not p
can come out afterwards because you
either if you jiggle it
or not enough and then there's always p
do you women have that problem or p
comes out afterwards i don't nice
good for you guys we have very different
vaginas i'm learning
um uh i
believe that because the way toilets are
designed we don't empty our bladders
entirely because we sit straight up if i
bend
forward i'll usually get most of it out
but if i just do it upright like this
and then walk away i'm like [ __ ] myself
to pee interesting that happens to me
sometimes i sit down and pee for
whatever reason forward
and i don't get it all out interesting
but and then when you guys shake it is
that to get the p out of the
dick part no i think it's just i think
it's just because there's drips on the
tip and you just want to
oh yeah and so what's up with the peeing
on girls what's that what's that
i hm what's wrong what's with peeing on
girl
appeal i've never done it but if i try
to use my imagination
i think it's just an expression i think
it's the same as like coming on a girl
probably it's just this
this raw expression of
he is very different than calm yeah i
know but it's like it's just this act of
like
it's like i i really don't know i mean
i've never done it and i don't have so
much of a desire to do it either
but it's like i think it's just probably
some women like being kind of dominated
so it's probably an active domination
or like disrespected or um
degraded yeah i feel like it's like more
it's a little more degrading
i think than coming on someone yes for
sure like i'm gonna pit your urinal
yes i had a guy pee on me once really
was it by at
your request or was it just it was we
were in the shower
i mean guys pee on all of us in the
shower i know that i've thought about it
but i've never peed on would you be mad
if i pj in the shower because i've
thought about it
just as like a joke
um probably i would just because i was
just kind of curious to see how you
would respond
you're in the shower yeah you're in the
shower it depends if you're
joking then i don't know i'll probably
laugh with you i was like ah whatever i
don't wanna
why don't i go there that's so cute
yeah in the chat this is sick
yeah in the shower not not in the bed or
something crazy
are you always don't you pee in the
shower don't always keep
showering
do you pee next to her and she doesn't
know you're peeing no we both pee in the
shower
but i've never i've never like peed onto
her
yeah right like i'll pee on the wall or
something
you guys are gross but then you're in
the shower you said it yourself
yeah you'd be on the wall why why would
i think to be on my wife
that's right you brush your teeth in the
shower what
you brush your teeth yeah i [ __ ] in the
shower too
i do everything in there you [ __ ] in the
shower
no i don't [ __ ] in the shower i my thing
is i can't
pee standing up like i really
in the shower yeah and then i feel it on
my leg and it's so hot
like as soon as i get in the shower i
pee it's like
it's like my brain just is functioning
like that
i'd like to hear about the dude who peed
on you though well
it was like i think what happened like a
couple years ago as guys are watching so
much porn that they thought
we all think like things have to be so
extreme and we have to out
it's like and i have so much compassion
for men because i feel like there's all
this pressure
when a guy has sex with you where
they're like i gotta choke her and i
gotta
pull her hair and i gotta put my finger
in her butt and i gotta like it's just
like
it's it's intense do you know what i
mean like i feel like they put a lot of
pressure on themselves they're like i
just gotta [ __ ] kill her
and give her a concussion and [ __ ] on
her face
i mean it's just like the laundry list
of things that i feel like guys think
they have to do
um so we had i found i found that in the
bedroom he was just always like
putting his hands in my mouth with with
no like
clear game plans like that
i got choking like and i didn't feel
like he was particularly into it either
like i was like i don't think you even i
feel like he just wanted a missionary
just just um but he was doing it for
your pleasure you think
i think guys think we watch as much porn
as they do
right because in porn girls are all
getting fish hooked and [ __ ]
dick slaps this is what they like yeah
yeah and they're just
exciting he thinks he's exciting your
eye socket yeah i mean it's just like
it looks like this yeah
like there's like just like weird [ __ ]
where you're just like i know you saw
that and now you think you have to do it
even though i don't think you're even
that into it
and um and so i remember we were in the
shower once
i don't remember how it happened i think
i definitely had a couple drinks and it
was maybe more receptive to it
and yeah he asked if i could he could
pee on me he's like i want to piss on
you or whatever it was
and so i was like all right we're in the
shower why not i should be cool about
this
i'm fun yeah yeah right right okay
i eat wings with the guys
um so i was like okay this is because he
had brought it up as a joke and i have a
theory that when guys bring things up
like as a
joke i'm like you want to do that
obviously you're floating right
oh okay like you're floating why would
he say it
so he floated it a couple times i was
like i think you want to do this
i'm just gonna so i get down on my knees
and he starts peeing on me and i look up
at him
and i burst out laughing
like literally burst out laughing and it
was like
and it was awful like it was not it
wasn't sexy
because then i also thought don't
sometimes when guys pee they fart
too sure that happens so i just like
don't fart please don't fart like
like then i start thinking about farts
and not every time though you could
certainly control it it's not like oh
i'm peeing on you and i'm gonna blast
ass in the shower
i just was like i couldn't take it
seriously yeah and
i was just like i don't know he was
peeing on your face
because you know how like women's
vaginas the way that they're shaped you
never know where the pee is going to go
it's like an origami
like oh really eyes every time that
happens to us
as well that's what i was wondering
because i was sort of like
i was more like what if he misses i feel
like i need to like help him
get it because i'll be embarrassed for
him if he misses
you thinking too much about this it
sounds like it should have just been fun
like like the fact that you laughed it
seems like that's a perfectly fine
response and that should have been fun
i know but isn't every man's greatest oh
when is that sorry i found this in
shredder's stomach he puked it out
and i'm just really curious where the
[ __ ] is this oh the wig
the the judge no it's the wig
with that wig we have to throw that wig
out dan
because we yeah we're all over the place
we're trying to figure out oh
he definitely ate some of the wig fibers
okay
yeah that's not good poor shredder puked
out all these weird fibers and i was
like what the [ __ ]
oh yeah it's good that he puked him up
yeah we should have um
we should have diana vacuum yeah
down here and we got to get a higher
quality
wig why did he eat so many is it a real
wig is it real hair
no no it's some [ __ ] [ __ ] but it
was like a huge clump of nylon fibers
and it really freaked me out i wonder
why he wanted to eat it
yeah he must have i wonder why he wanted
to eat it as well
it could have been he was eating food on
the floor maybe i picked it up
okay i'm glad i figured that out that's
not alfredo's the small white one what's
up
what's shredder he's the little yorkie
is it yeah
huh you want to see him he's sleeping i
won't bother him
yeah you want to see him you can't okay
jesus so um i hate dogs
so um yeah i don't that seems like it
should have been fun like if someone's
peeing on you and you laugh that seems
like a perfectly acceptable response
but i think we've been trained
and tell me if you disagree or it's a
cultural or american
or whatever like i think women have been
trained at least i was trained that
never embarrass a man if you embarrass a
man or laugh at him like
he'll kill you oh my god that's the
worst thing you can do is laugh at a man
unless he makes a joke that's not funny
in which case you have did you not know
him very well
no we've been together for like eight
months maybe oh because i feel like
i feel like if i peed on well i guess
we've been we've been
together for a long time maybe yeah i
mean eight months you're still
it's still like honeymoon you know yeah
and i think i think
well i just think also his mentality was
like i think there's a lot of guys that
like have done too much with porn and
are getting desensitized and when
they have actual sex with an actual
woman there's a vagina there it's just
like not enough
you know like their tolerance is getting
higher and higher
you know that's what they say happens to
that's why they say
bill clinton [ __ ] kids and all that
it's the power
you understand it's the power it's
never enough well and also the
adrenaline real clinton well i was just
saying
you get these senses that's what they
say happens with all these deaths i'm
going to get pizza emojis in my comments
i'm going to be emailing you pizza
references
the queue and honors are coming after me
now what the [ __ ]
is that trisha yes how's everything
going with trisha really good actually
yeah she said something about me on her
podcast she like made an apology to me
on her podcast on her podcast or her
instagram stories
on her podcast why do you guys have beef
no
i think she had didn't like me back in
the day
she didn't like me at all and
we asked her to be on the podcast oh
she responded to she thought she was
responding to her team but she responded
to
our team she said a bunch of really bad
things about oh my god way
really to our team by accident she
thought it was to her team
what what a psycho and then she
apologized
yeah and then she apologized does he
remember what she said
we need a camera
yeah basically they said to me they're
like do you want to see these emails
they're crazy and i was like no but i'll
send them to you guys
yes send them to me i'd love to read
them okay i'll confront her
should i ask them for them now that
would be so [ __ ] awesome
i'd love to know how she communicates
behind the scenes you know what i mean
as a business woman um she puts gnarly
[ __ ] in emails
all right can you send me the trisha
paytas emails
i feel like i'm gonna regret this
what's that benton and benton was a
really big fan and it
kind of broke his heart that she was so
mean about me uh well she's
crazy don't yeah i mean look dude i'm
fine
i don't know i was just i was trying to
she likes me i'd probably be more
concerned
i was yeah exactly i'm trying to consult
benton it's like if you're a trisha
paytas fan you just gotta [ __ ]
be ready for anything dude you can't
live with her i like her i like that i
like someone that just is like [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
yes she is too she is no no can i can i
they sent me her email address sure is
it hotmail okay that's actually the
craziest thing about her
well
can i get screen grabs yeah
of the emails she sent about me the
psycho emails
huh has anyone actually died from corona
she'll put him on the internet benton is
like please don't start this
am i starting a youtube beef she's
friends with us she's she's not going to
be with you
yeah don't ruin the fun i like her
when people don't like me it makes me
like them more oh really
interesting i'm like good to call i have
some exciting news for you whitney
really pull this up ian right here that
i've got highlighted
you have a 5 out of 5 stars on wiki feet
oh can i tell you something sure
i don't i believe it's so weird in this
world
i feel like i deserve more
on a lot of things but i feel like i
deserve less in this area
this is the only area of my career where
i feel like i deserve less
so you're aware of your high rating yes
because
taylor tomlinson a comedian um
tried to step to me sorry for the pun uh
and she was like i have a 4.5 on wiki
feet and i was like [ __ ] let's see what
i have and i realized i had a five out
of five yeah [ __ ] her
she's disgusting what do you think
it is because my feet are oh that's
going to go on wick
here do me a favor that is going to be
up on wiki feet before this
episode that's the minute this is up
what are you thinking
about all over
yeah hold on this toenail fell off
oh no hold on
if you listen closely you can hear the
splatters of a thousand [ __ ] shots
hitting a keyboard
of a thousand uh men you're pissing on
girls faces
so this i feel like this toe is long as
long as this one
it's like an e-t-toe and i feel like
it's gross some people
have so i've i've learned a lot about it
because i'm on wiki feet now
so there's the roman toe formation and
the greek toe formation
i know it's way too much so you have a
really good greek toe formation which is
when
the second the the you know the second
one the second one is bigger than the
then the big toe right it's like as long
i would say
it looks longer but what is it what's
that what is your theory on why guys are
in defeat it's because they look like
little dicks
no i think it's just demeaning the they
like the whole not just guys apparently
right oh yeah women love it
women i have a high arch oh look at that
that's apparently a big deal that i have
a high arch
but you know the other theory i had this
um neuroscientist on the podcast was
that when
kids um when babies crawl around
ila you should listen very intently to
this when they can't get their mom's
attention
they see their feet and they develop a
fetish
because they're crawling and they're
following them
and they see the mom's feet and they get
obsessed with them because they equate
it with their mom's attention but
they're
crawling babies i think it's a dominance
thing too because like
if somebody's interacting with your feet
on a sexual level
they're degrading themselves feet are
dirty
they're worn on it's like you step on
somebody
it's that whole thing so it's men that
want to be dominated yeah and and
vice versa they want to be treated like
[ __ ] or something what is that though
that's a
that's something their mom dropped the
ball
[Music]
but also i mean there's a lot of people
they're just
looking for beautiful feet right just
they're just like analyzing it no
it's sexual you think someone's just
spending their free time there
they're making it off
i mean i find it more disturbing that
someone's just looking there
in a non-sexual way if they're just like
yeah that's actually way more disturbing
they're like oh [ __ ] four point they're
like
whitney hmm 4.8
i don't like people touching my feet i
i would rather have a guy eat my ass
than suck my toes
there's gonna be a lot of people just
wanting to hear that my [ __ ] smells
better than
at this point but there are guys that
want to suck on feet
oh yeah have you have you had that
happen to you
but do you not think they're kind of
trying to suck little dicks they're not
little no
really that's your thoughts that is so
funny that's such a little bit it's like
a really little dick
that's what i'm saying so go with me
let's folk you in on this [ __ ]
yeah so then the toe the foot is just
basically a dick tree
um no i think it's more of a
well-manicured type deal really
um yeah exactly also some true
foot-fetish okay
some people are also into like the
smells like
you know sometimes you can get off to
the smells which i personally have
um whoa whoa whoa stop the [ __ ]
you smell feet occasionally i've been
known to smell feet yeah
holy [ __ ] do you like stinky feet
no it's just kind of like musk i guess
you could
you could you could um compare it like
smelling your girl's underwear after day
of her wearing it
bro we've been talking about feet for
like a month how are we only learning
this right now
bro you do that what the panties thing
yeah
oh hell yeah oh zach you're such a
gnarly dude i love it
i was so you're into like cliff's charge
no this just like i don't know there's
something about like a women's natural
scent that i find very attractive
let me ask you do you have sex with
girls on their periods
sure yeah he even calls it uh red wings
right yeah
but he says the red wings isn't that
when you eat out a girl in her period
yeah yeah yeah that's the worst you're
dope
where you're gnarly dude
whitney wouldn't you find it liberating
if a guy like
zach comes along and he's like i worship
every part of your body
you are insecure about your feet i love
your feet i want to smell them
so like it makes you feel more secure
all the police
i immediately would call my security
company
yeah no i just don't think we need to go
it's i'm not insecure about my feet like
i
i just know what purpose they're
supposed to serve
and it's it's it's to climb rocks and
[ __ ] you know i mean like it's just
weird because they're
so ugly there's something just like odd
about it hey zach you ever pee on a girl
uh in the shower one time yeah one time
did she know you were peeing on her
yeah she was into it was it sexual or
funny
no it was sexual it was definitely
sexual yeah it's a good time
what did you pee what is what do you get
out of that where did you
what do you think what did you where did
you pee on her body
uh her boobs it was like it was like she
was on her knees and like i peed on her
boobs yeah so whitney asked what do you
get out of it
um no because i'm a very respectable
i resp i i respect women i don't i don't
demean them i treat them right i grew up
that way
however that's like literally what a
psychopath says
i uh i don't know i respect women don't
have to run around being like i respect
women
i was raised right he has a good
i'm gonna have to point like 75 of this
episode
i'm like back in the game and i just
have lots of questions thank you
you're ill an ill man but yeah i'm
single again i think okay
turn off your camera
thank you dm zach
zach is uh i'm good 23
exactly
give it away but he lives with his
parents that's the kinkiest thing you've
said so far
no wonder you're in the [ __ ] pose
okay i don't think i realize how young
you are okay yeah
i know we're [ __ ] dude i mean the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] that's going down is like
is totally well i mean and also i hooked
up with this guy who's a doctor he's a
vet he's my vet
and they the choking you know in porn
like it's always like i'm gonna jump you
hooked up with your
vet wait continue the story because i
want to circle back to that
but it's like i was like well during the
painting i was like let me just hook up
with doctors only they seem to know what
they're
they know about the droplets like like
well no
like i just i felt weird hooking up with
anyone that wasn't a medical
professional during a pandemic
he's a vet though to be fair he is a vet
to be fair
dogs did have covid to be fair there
were some cases
but our vets doctors i mean we're going
to split hairs here
uh i don't know you're the one whose dog
just peeped up hair so
then i don't think you [ __ ] the doctor
if i'm gonna be honest with you
i think you [ __ ] the vet
[Music]
and i don't want to like take away
anything from your achievements but
it's like it's like in a doc a doctor
that's not a psychopath
yeah it's like a poor doctor a poor
doctor
if you [ __ ] the chiropractor would you
say you [ __ ] a doctor no
yeah okay that's like pseudoscience
isn't it yeah [ __ ]
act like a like a crystal guy that's
like
[ __ ] a massage therapist okay good
we're on the same page
you even need a degree to be a
chiropractor no
[ __ ] i i went to a chiropractor and
it [ __ ] up my
entire body he had me hang
like in a hedge i mean it might have
been a sexual thing now that i look back
at it i
think i was molested i'm coming forward
um it was like he wrapped my head in a
leather thing and hung me off the ground
and i had to just like [ __ ]
i was like how is this legal this is not
science oh my god i feel like everybody
who has back pain
will try the chiropractic the
chiropractor because they're like [ __ ]
it you know because so many people
recommend them like i had a
the person that i was exercising with
was saying oh you got to go to this
person i sent everyone to them
or and then even even my doctor one time
sent me to
acupuncture i couldn't believe it
acupuncture a real doctor centered you
actually a doctor at kaiser sent me to
acupuncture
like that's freaky but also let's circle
back to kaiser in a second because
i fell off a horse once and whoa whoa
whoa i thought you didn't ride them
i wasn't riding it i was [ __ ] it
potholes
[Laughter]
dry humping it and
well it was bareback which is why i was
like fell off so easily and i had no
rains or anything
and i just like slid off the back and
like cracked my l4 like one of my
and i went into kaiser i've never been
to kaiser before i'm sure they're gonna
sue me for saying this
um but i went in and they were like oh
yeah you have a
herniated disc and all this stuff and i
was sitting there for like four hours
and i just was like let me just like
record this for instagram because i'm
just like i need some content i've been
[ __ ] sitting here so i was like can i
take a picture
of the x-ray where i have the crack so i
can post it on instagram because they
were like following me with going to the
hospital and like
and he's like i'm not allowed to show
you this i'm usually not allowed to show
you this confidential i was like come on
like he like recognized me or something
i took the picture and i was like oh is
this the crack in my vertebrae he's like
yeah and i looked at it
and i was like i think that's my iud
oh my god and he was like
oh what a this one
was an er doctor [ __ ] what
i don't know i have i'm i think kaiser's
a little sketchy but i don't know if
you've lost faith at all i would lose
faith
in all doctors right i was like that
little crack like
that's there's a little string that
comes off of it you know iuds are like
he thought that was it on the x-ray i
hate what that's insane
i don't like wild yeah i don't like
knowing that
i don't like no i think doctors are
supposed to be infallible gods
well i dated a doctor a real human
doctor md
uh a couple years ago and he said
it's called a practice that's why we
call it a practice and not the
championships
because we're pro we're doing the best
we can with the information we have
wow what a douche
i mean it's like because think about
like everyone
have you noticed like at this level of
our like
age things will happen where you go to
the doctor and they're like they are
doing a thing they used to do
and you're like oh that wasn't remember
when they used to hit our knee with a
little mini
yeah that hasn't happened in a long time
that wasn't a thing
right that's just sort of they phased
out just kind of fun
though i always look forward to it i
mean i still do what was it to test your
reflexes like that wasn't anything
yeah that wasn't real they used to put
thermometers in our butts like there
were lots
you know i had a doctor who used to spit
my mouth that hasn't happened in a while
you go stick out your tongue and you
just talk a little bit down my throat
eyes are into spitting in your mouth
that's
that's hot i think that's actually hot
zach you ever spin someone's mouth
in someone's mouth uh no okay never done
that yeah
that's a shame you're gonna have to yeah
i mean i've spit on other places but no
never the mouth
okay that's not what we asked
i ask you for a list of places you've
spit on a human being
yeah i think um chiropractors is sort of
i think kind of a scam
like i remember i went to this
chiropractor and he
stood me up in a mirror in front of the
mirror and just and put his hand he was
behind me and he put his hands under me
and was just like
see how crooked your body is and he was
just like holding my boob like
it was so weird i look back and i'm like
oh that freaks
yeah when i went to one he was also
telling me that
just like you see how crooked this is
like and then supposedly
it just does something and that should
fix you like it doesn't make any sense
dude they just they come out they come
out the corner of the room like john
cena doing like a body slam on your back
and then they're like you're good to go
but also what they when they crack your
joints like when you crack your
fingers which i do it does feel better
until it feels worse like it makes it
temporarily feel better and then you get
addicted to it so it's sort of like
you do feel a little bit high for a
second
when they crack your bones because the
fluid is released yeah
and he's like okay i'm gonna stretch
this muscle
i'm gonna stretch this muscle out and
it's just gonna relieve the pain
and he's sitting there i was there when
he was doing it and he was like
you know it's like yeah and it's just
like all right dude
[Music]
enough of the [ __ ] yeah it's just a
little it's a deep massage is
feels good that's kind of what they're
doing i feel like yeah
you know and then i just feel pressure
to be like yeah that feels amazing and
then you've already spent the money so
you're like
in on it and then it's like placebo
effect or something i feel like
and then a week later you have pain
again yeah
you're just like well that was nothing
apparently we do the most damage to our
body
while we're sleeping what position do
you sleep in oh that's so true
yeah i sleep really weird yeah you're a
weird sleeper
i think that's why your back's [ __ ] up
where how do you sleep
i mean i don't know i i fall asleep on
my side but then she's everywhere she's
like
that's bad do you have how many pillows
do you use
dude it's when she falls asleep
everything is crazy
like she'll she'll fall asleep on her
back but then i'll wake up and she's
just like
my form my bed at my parents house i
don't know why
like it had a i would always somehow end
up all the way to the
the edge of it and like sleep like that
really yeah
i don't know why that's messed up yeah
would you wake up and then be like oh i
gotta go to sleep right
yeah because it was uncomfortable yeah
that probably [ __ ] you up for life
so you just sleep like a crazy like uh
you wear off a bit yeah you also crunch
your teeth in your sleep i can hear this
awful sound where goes
grinding do you sleep with something in
like a mouth guard
i don't have a guard to do i need a
guard
i don't know do i do it a lot
occasionally
because i asked the dentist one time and
he said like you you would wake up with
pain or something
so maybe it's not a problem it just
sounds gnarly but have you um
had them look at your teeth and see if
the enamel's worn down
i had i was recently at a dentist and
didn't say anything about that so
i think it must be not i think you're
good
okay how do you sleep like a perfect
angel every night on my
i sleep so here's my story
if you'll allow me to indulge here's my
story
what's your story well because i have i
grown up had terrible sleep paralysis
oh yeah and it and i and i had a theory
at least i don't know if it was true or
not i think it was
is that when i would sleep in any other
position
other than my side i would get i would
have these horrible
night terror sleep paralysis and so i've
been
like absolutely trained
and that i cannot sleep in any other
position other than my side
otherwise something terrible is going to
happen to me is it only one side or
either side
either side huh and so but but that
being said i sleep on my side
i don't move and i never have any back
pain i'm like perfection is like a weird
phenomenon it doesn't have any back pain
and i'm fat i feel like i've never met
anyone that doesn't have any back
some kind of background i have no back
pain and i think it's just because
i just i don't [ __ ] around and he also
has perfect teeth like whenever he goes
to the dentist
he doesn't need anything done nothing i
mean
i mean it makes me upset because every
time i go they're like oh yeah we got to
change your whole
everything which i didn't realize how
much dental stuff is genetic
yeah stop doing that
uh your teeth are kind of pointy
up here and you know in china they're uh
it's very in vogue right now
to not only eat bats but also
shave your teeth yeah
and i went over there i was in hong kong
like a couple years ago
what are we doing what are we shaving
our teeth to do like
your teeth in china would be very highly
uh regardless why because i have points
here yeah yeah
these pointy ones really i always wanted
to shave these down when i was a kid
because i like
thought it was cool when it all lines up
it's very hot what's your um
do you know your genetic background 99.9
jewish european jail which part of
europe
lithuania i don't know some [ __ ]
some [ __ ] country
lithuania do you think that's how it's
cornell
some [ __ ] [ __ ] country
[Laughter]
because these canines are like specific
to certain parts of the world
oh really so it's it's it's it's uh
eastern europe it's not leukemia
is it not where is that i think so
that's a good i don't know i think it is
yeah yeah i feel like that's like middle
europe
well it's like it's like you started
geography podcast
yeah i mean it's not like it's not cool
europe i know that
it's like lame europe not like covered
europe
right yeah but it's uh and you've never
had a cavity
i had one i just had when i was a kid i
had one tiny little
like thing
do you floss every night yeah see i
really struggle with flossing
you know what changed my life i floss
every night and i still have problems
you have amazing teeth you know what
changed my life these little
flossing tools you can do it so fast and
it's like
easy the string awful i hate the string
awful
the string's the worst but here's can i
tell you something that's going to be
shitty i was using that and someone was
like you realize how bad for them oh
yeah
i know that like hey i love those too
and then i felt like an [ __ ] using
them someone shamed me
yeah i know that but i didn't slump i
feel like there's certain things we have
to
just do anyway hey whitney how much
pollution does this horseshit
cost
and i feel very comfortable saying that
i do not know that yeah you don't want
to know
have you broken any bones you love um
be weird if you didn't remember i don't
think you would you would know
immediately
um i don't know if i broke my nose when
i was a kid
something happened to my nose oh really
what happened
i was i was like in kindergarten i don't
remember
and no one told you everyone's just kept
it from you i never probably i never
checked back you probably what happened
there
we should
no i probably didn't break it yeah i
think not
yeah yeah that's interesting so i wonder
what's your back
stuff from sitting all day oh i have um
also scoliosis so i think that
doesn't help for sure are your boobs
even
[Music]
yeah they're good mine were crooked and
i had to get them fixed
really that helped your back pain no it
didn't help my back pain getting fake
boobs
made my back pain worse but there's an
issue with
uncrooked boobs that can [ __ ]
sometimes yeah sometimes if you
sort of have scoliosis your boobs are
just like ones up here and one you know
they're just like look like a self
dolly painting yeah you're just like
so it's gotten worse since you got
fake boobs you said not the they're
they're super i mean they look like
crocodile eyes coming out of a pond now
i mean they're perfectly symmetrical now
but back pain is worse slightly worse
because they have to cut through some
muscles
so then you end up compensating with the
wrong muscles and then you have a little
there's a lot of weight there too now
isn't it
um it's not a ton of weight i mean
they're pretty
huge right but yes you are
[ __ ] around with your body balance
but apparently
carrying purses is one of the worst
things women
because we're always carrying a person
on one side like eight pounds
you know for 20 years yeah so that's a
big thing too so i've got like
like bags on my front a purse on my side
it's like of course my back hurts
but i did start sleeping on my back
after i got fake boobs because you have
to sleep on your back
have to so that it heals yeah you kind
of i sleep like a vampire
um in a coffin and because i was also so
afraid that they were gonna like
fall out i don't know i was just like
weirded out by the whole thing it's just
like such a weird
thing to have and so i would like sleep
with my arms crossed in front of them
and my hands like holding them up
oh wow and sleeping on my back has
really changed
like it's helped like i sleep like this
i wake up all [ __ ] up
yeah oh really so my so my boobs
the surgery kind of helped my back by
accident just because i started sleeping
differently
maybe you should try sleeping i mean
well it doesn't matter because once you
fall asleep you're all over the place
i'll try it do you sleep on a soft
mattress or a hard mattress
tempurpedic i told you tempur-pedic you
said no
but it's not the more you where you
control the height
and the the no that's the nursing home
that's the highest
no no i mean the i mean the the the
firmness you do it by a number
uh uh no it just comes it's just very
mushy it's sort of like oh okay
like you melt into it kind of oh very
yes it's super mushy
and then it's taking me a long time to
figure out the pillow situation because
your neck is everything but i
do a tempur-pedic pillow and i like kind
of jam it under my neck
so that my spine is straight i know i'm
a
catch sleeping isn't [ __ ] up for
everyone
that's what you don't like once you're
over like 25 you're just
sleeping as such a mother
but it's so [ __ ] important but it's
also so telling see you guys have slept
with each other for so long like
it's so weird how different people sleep
dude
i dated a couple guys who just slept
with their face in the pillow like
the weirdest i ever saw someone sleep
he's this dude i don't know why it's
stuck in my memory
he was a really weird guy he frankly
gave me like um
american psycho vibes i only knew him
for like a couple days he was at my
friend's house
and this was in college so whatever he
was sleeping on the floor
just on the floor bro no blanket or
anything and he was sleeping like this
no dude psychopath like i swear to god i
was like
900 i couldn't believe what i was seeing
he was like
just totally like you ever get on a
plane and someone's like sitting on the
plane and they're just like
i hate that all asleep you're like what
the [ __ ] they're
pretending how do you do that they're
not really asleep
yeah i think they're pretending wait a
second
i'm realizing the last 15 years of my
life that's all just people trying to
avoid talking to me on a plane
yeah like think of pretending to be
asleep like if i'm on a plane and i'm
tired i'll do this but i'm not
necessarily sleeping i'm just miserable
and trying to
you think it's trying to go to a happier
place silence because
if you went excuse me they'd be like
yeah guaranteed
i guarantee you they're awake the idea
that we sleep on planes is so [ __ ]
weird
like just flying through the sky
asleep like i don't think i've ever
slept on a plane i just can't do it
also like the most incredible thing you
can possibly imagine doing you're
40 000 feet above the
earth traveling 600 miles per hour and
you're just like man [ __ ] this
like i'm so relaxed this is such a
relaxing experience inhaling people's
farts and [ __ ]
it's too much but you have you guys done
any live shows or traveling shows
where you do it live in theaters we
don't travel
we're sent we're sent we're sedentary
creatures
you know we did a live show in la and it
was fun but like the whole touring thing
we were just like
[ __ ] [ __ ] all that just not fun for you
no mm-hmm even before the pandemic was
just not yeah
huh how's the pandemic what about you
i yeah no i do tour a lot i just did my
first
touring gig this past weekend the
driving get it out
it was [ __ ] weird they were honking
at you
that's so weird usually a sign of
disrespect
still probably is [ __ ] you don't think
that's changed
these tickets so [ __ ] expensive well
because it's also in california
you couldn't get out of your car so i
sort of thought it was gonna be like
people that were like sitting on the
hood of their cars
well they have a their radio is tuned
okay
right so they can hear me
and then they would honk if something
was funny is so weird
it's impressive like it's just it's it's
also like a thousand cars it's not one
car
a thousand people just honking at you
but i
must say like not to be a dork there was
something kind of magical about
it like of like with this resilience of
like people were so
desperate to connect and get out of
their homes and just sort of like [ __ ]
it this sucks for everyone here but
we're gonna like
get through it there was something kind
of triumphant about it
um it also was really alarming to think
about like
as human beings what we're able to get
used to because after like 10 minutes of
the honking it felt normal
i was like all right and i was just like
it's amazing what we're able to just get
used to
so quickly yeah you are you actually are
you're
currently on tour now you're actually
doing a lot of shows it looks like
whitney cummings dot com slash tour
october 15th come get cover oh you're
traveling dude
how did you feel traveling you felt safe
or are you
super paranoid i feel like
i'm paranoid enough to when i go
i feel safe you know like i kind of like
i do the testing
i tested before i went i tested when i
got back i we did double masks
like on the flights there was no one
next to us
the thing that really bothered me
actually i hadn't been out
wearing the mask for a long period of
time yet and it was just more like
it kind of made me nauseous to just be
inhaling the same air
yeah i really hate it i actually spend
like
long days with it because when i go to
the teddy fresh office
i mean sometimes i'm there from like
nine until four
and the whole time is with the mask and
you get
i'm like i don't know if i just have
horrible breath no i hate it
yeah it's awful yes i don't like
smelling my own breath i was like dude i
don't want to know how bad my
breath is it makes sense and it's like i
don't know if i'm hot or cold
it's like everything just feels weird
and because it's like kind of stuffy in
your mouth
in your face and then i and then like
it's just you're like sweat you're
sw it's like is this sweater is the spit
like your
your face is like damp like is it swampy
in there
like i feel like i'm also eating less
because i'm so paranoid of eating
when i'm out like i don't want to touch
anything so if i have food i'm like
okay how do i not touch anything
it's just like everything is just
exhausting everything is
too hard like like the easy things are
now really hard so it's just more
annoying like i got back and like i'm
good at traveling like i used to do 80
cities a year like i feel like just
doing one flight from denver to l.a i
got back and i was like i gotta take a
nap
just like just going to the bathroom in
the airport was like a 20 minutes
it just was like yeah it's that [ __ ]
it's just exhausting it's unnecessarily
exhausting
you know i was listening to um great
podcast
and the epidemiologist was saying very
good things he was saying
there's a lot of good things on the
horizon one the vaccine is a couple
months away from being approved
so he thinks vaccines will be widely
available
by mid next year
and then there's also then we just need
people to believe in them and take that
well [ __ ] them i'll take it and they
could suck they could suck
if they don't like but in terms of like
touring and stuff like how
you know because stand-up comedy we're
basically asking people to come
exhale on it affects your breath
so he had a really good argument he was
like you know
if people are scared of covid they're
going to get the vaccine
because if if they're if they're not
scared of kovid they'll just go about
their normal business
and if they are scared to it's where the
point where it's impeding their life
they're just going to get the vaccine
because he said you know when he was a
kid there was a
like smallpox or some [ __ ] i don't
remember but he was like people people
didn't want to get the vaccine then
either
but he's like people are scared of
smallpox they got the vaccine and that
shit's gone now
and then for you as an employer so say
you're going to go back to work in
person
are you requiring your everyone you work
with to get the vaccine
that's a good question we haven't even
discussed it i'm pretty sure
currently i just i require everyone to
wear a mask
can we legally do that i don't know i
don't know what's going to be
spicy i would strongly like to prove it
it's like the new
like std testing like have you like let
me see
like i would be like i need some proof i
would probably say
if you don't have the paperwork to prove
it you have to wear a mask
yeah i think the mask is going to be a
long time
and here for a long time because of all
the yeah yeah
it'll be it'll be a few years i think
before the virus is like gone
well also it's like it also makes you
realize there's a couple things we never
should have been doing like we never
should have been shaking hands oh my god
that's
people still try to shake my hand yeah
i'm like dude what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you doing someone came
to our house uh
what was it for but he would just shake
my hand i was like dude
no way bro like what yeah yeah
he's here with him people are still
stuck in their old ways where they're
like oh
it's disrespectful it's disrespectful to
give me a virus
give me one of these but people
just what's up like hey we don't need to
touch each other it's so weird as humans
how
awkward it gets when we don't touch each
other when we meet it's just like such
an odd
what else is what else is it that we've
been doing that we shouldn't be doing
i think this might not be you guys as
much but in
my business like we used to drive to a
meeting to have an
in-person like general meeting for a job
you might
get and it was like half your day right
yeah no i have meetings like that you
like drive
45 minutes you sit there you talk and
shoot the [ __ ] for an hour you leave
like like a job uh interview
basically yeah for listening like it's
like an audition or a
general meeting like that and always
should have been over facetime yeah
never should have been driving for that
yeah right i'm now at the point where
i'm like if i go somewhere in person
you have to pay me for my time like i
now realize
how much time we used to waste i know
yeah absolutely
yeah but no promise of employment so i
think there's like that
yeah i feel i feel in like five years
everything will people will be shaking
hands and
doing all the jump shots dating i know
you guys uh
can't totally relate like first date
face time
really like why not why not because
saves you some time of meeting some
creeps because you show up you drive
half an hour you get there and they show
up and you're like oh and i have to sit
through this for three if we just like
knock out like
a 30 minute like let's just make sure
you look that's so
interesting within the general range of
your photo
and i also like it because i can kind of
see your place because i can't go back
to your place
for the first couple dates because i'm
not a what about the virtual backgrounds
did it happen to you that someone oh my
god that's so funny too yeah
that's so poor nude virtual background
dating
here i am in my bank account
someone that we work with um like we
hired their service
and we had a meeting with a few people
and one of them
had this like virtual background of a
really nice bedroom
or like a nice it was like a kitchen
home office yeah
it was like almost real you know like it
almost
fools you i had a crazy thing i was
on with someone like a business person
like a producer or something
and this wasn't a virtual background but
she had this like bookshelf in the
background with all these amazing books
and you could kind of read them and
i was like god you have such an amazing
it was all like music it was like jimi
hendrix and all these like beautiful
talk books
and i was like oh those are so cool like
you have such good taste in books or
something and then she pulled out one oh
no this is a photo of a bookshelf it's
an artist
there's some artists that'll do that and
i just was like oh i've lost
so much perspective yeah
when i first moved to la uh this i must
have been
22 and i was just like an idiot going to
like hollywood parties because i thought
you like
made it by like someone would see you a
party and go you
like i'm signing you and i'm going to
put you in the picture so i was like
at like val kilmer's house or or some
[ __ ] and um
i went that was the first hollywood
party i went to i split my pants at val
kilmer's house and i was wearing red red
thung underwear and everyone thought i
was like on my period and i was like i'm
not on my period it's red underwear
i was dancing and you must you got
really low
yeah yeah i'm like a funny dancer
i'm like uh like that's my thing
right um and i was like i didn't have
any money at the time so i had bought
these pants at victoria's secret like
you know they have like clothes like
they used to like victoriasecret.com
and they were like these like remember
when like were you ever in like a black
pants phase
ela like that's what those were like our
going-out pants
black pants you never had like black
he's like you always
and i went to this agent's some party at
this like fancy agent's house and they
were like all these like amazing books
in this like beautiful mansion and i was
like oh my god like
he's educated and erudite and like has
this mansion
and i left my purse because i was like
drunk an idiot
and then the next day i like went back
to get my purse and all the books were
gone
what what i was like so weird
there's a service where you can have
someone bring you
no way and they're highlighted and
dog-eared and it's like hemingway
and oscar wilde it is
like books for a day rent
believe that rent a fancy bookshelf
how do you live with yourself if you've
done that mirrored hollywood agent
i feel like that's the least gross thing
do you do that's shocking
dude i was like oh my god are you moving
like what's happening
and i was like oh my god see i've never
i don't work with agents and all these
people
you don't have agents at all no no no we
don't
we don't do [ __ ] with nobody i've tried
but i always don't like them
and i find that they don't because
you're in traditional media and
our thing is different you know like no
you guys
broke traditional it's over you took you
you broke it
i mean if i've learned anything these
last six months
yeah tv's kind of dead well do you need
an agent to connect you to like if a
network wants
uh or has an offer or has a supposition
they go to your agent so that whole
thing is just kind of
doesn't exist in our world because yeah
they'll just
email you yeah yeah i know it's such a
it's it's really
it's it's amazing what jobs are becoming
obsolete so quickly
you know like i i um heard that
the you know when you go through like a
toll road um
you pay a toll booth worker you know
like there's like a total booth worker
that takes like
five dollars or whatever apparently now
that toll is just paying the salary of
the tollbooth worker
it's just canceling each other like it
doesn't it's not necessary you're just
paying for that person
but that you know what i mean so it's
like that's kind of what's happening
it's sort of like these sort of like
fake jobs that are these fake industry
standards right
um that are in even the last two years
have just like gone away
you know those agents take so much
[ __ ] money from you
it's wild and also it's made you realize
like how much money
artists weren't getting because it used
to be like okay i do a tv show i make a
tv
show there's executives there's
publicist there's marketing people
there's like
70 people that need to get paid and then
the advertisers like you end up getting
like four percent and then i started
doing like instagram partnership stuff
you're like why are you paying me all
this money and you're like no
oh yeah exactly it just goes to you
directly
they can pay you can pay you way less
than they pay traditional media and you
still make way more
but you're just paying for the people
that are obstacles to you making the
thing you want to make it's a bunch of
people that are like giving you shitty
notes and telling you what to do and
yeah
who to hire and you're like why are you
taking a cut of this you're the one
that's standing in the way of this being
good
yeah exactly that's when we tried to
work with an agent that's exactly what
happened
it just felt like it was standing in the
way i was just like taking a car
i was like dude and this is stupid
goodbye
you know yeah they don't get a lawyer
like is there illegal stuff
i just pay i pay hourly when i need
legal yeah there's like a law firm that
we use and
wow because i know i know entertainment
lawyers sometimes you they work on
retainer for a percentage
but we just pay because we have the we
have attorneys that we use for
teddy fresh also but it's just per
thing that comes up when something comes
up we send it to them
like how much you pay your attorney like
five percent ten percent five percent
that's crazy so you get ten not on my
not on the podcaster
not unless it's something that like he
negotiated the deal so
it's like in tv which i think is
changing very quickly there's lots of
like back end
and points and you have to audit and all
that kind of stuff so they are
super involved in all that stuff you
know i did
well in tv like tv was worked for me for
a while but it's just like
it's amazing how quickly it broke like i
noticed it when i would go on like
talk shows like fallon or kimmel or
these shows or i would go on
on to do like a late night set or do the
couch or whatever to promote something
and then as soon as the show was over
they'd be like hey can you hear the
elements for your social media
i'd be like aren't i on your show right
you're like can you put this on your
instagram and i'm like i thought this
was your show yeah
this is your platform you know it just
sucks wow
yeah that's so now i'm going to do a
late night talk show
and then i have to put it on mine like i
thought you were supposed to be
benefiting me
yeah big time it's like it's just get me
on hot ones i don't even do any of this
totally you know but the numbers are
just
wild like if you really like look at the
numbers uh
it doesn't make a lot of sense like if
you're going to go through like
developing a tv show and you're like
okay so a hit tv show
gets like my instagram stories do better
than that like why yeah
yeah yeah yeah like yeah we were working
on developing a tv show
and ultimately we're like this is not
gonna be worth it in any way
we're just felt so discouraging on yeah
on all levels possible like the
work process was exhausting and there's
so many people
to even just get to the first step of
presenting it to someone
yeah and we're gonna make less money
financially it was like
we'll make way less money than anything
else we can do
it would be the worst financially it
would have to be something that you
really
wanted to like if you want to do like a
travel show or if you want like like a
docu-series or like animation
like it would have to be like fun for
you here's the thing though i'm like
i'm like i can i feel like i could do
all that i mean obviously the logistical
issue is really
the most challenging thing and
undertaking those but ultimately it's
like what do they have they have
they have money to put up front but i
have that
and they have like i guess someone to do
all the logistics but once you have that
infrastructure yourself
it's totally worthless to you it's
worthless and i think you have to
realize like why you're doing a certain
thing like you know
i it took me a while to do podcasting
because i i
didn't think i was interesting enough on
my own it's an emotional reason like i
didn't look at it
business-wise like i was just like oh i
need all these people to help me in
order to be interesting or compelling
you know like i and i need like wardrobe
and makeup and
you know to do it this traditional way
that and have a machine behind me
because like to you know because that's
how advertising used to work and i need
to be on billboards because like who
would want to hear me talk for two hours
you know like it took me a long time
like what you guys do is such an
incredible skill
finally somebody says it is his art i
mean you're just
artists this craft no but it is it's
like the ability to
you know have conversations with people
and make people feel comfortable
and not feel pressured to make
everything like super highly produced
all the time like it's just changing
what people want
um and the highly the highly produced
product is not necessarily better for
the
viewer they're not necessarily into it
no i think it's like i think people are
in a place now where they'd rather have
you know authentic and for lack of a
better word just like sloppy
and funny and casual then like i think
they're suspicious if something's too
highly produced i think it's the
reason we have the president we have is
sort of like yeah he's a [ __ ] show but
like he knows he's a [ __ ] show and
we what we see is what we get it doesn't
feel calculated
and it doesn't feel just feels like i'd
rather see like an authentic mess
than an inauthentic perfect presentation
you know but tv i think for me it was
like i
never had like a family and i just like
the
making a tv show is so fun if you have
the right people
it's like camp yeah you know it's like
you're putting on plays with your
friends like that's what i love about it
it's
but it's becoming a less viable business
right well i feel like we've yeah
i feel like we've kind of achieved that
in a way here because now we've got like
what
sure ian dan zak ab
and we've got this really fun
collaborative uh
thing here so but just to kind of wrap
this conversation up with me if i can go
back to the issue of you putting your
dick down a horse's foreskin so like how
deep would you say you go
um i would say if this
is the horse's like it's like a fupa
like the horse
you have to reach it i mean sometimes
what i'll do is i'll scratch it's
okay you guys are right horse people are
[ __ ] nice let's hear it
he'll scratch his back and relax him
so that his dick comes out
wait is he turned on when the dick comes
out just from scratching the back
i think he's just like relaxed yeah i
don't think he's like preparing to
[ __ ] me yeah i think he's just relaxed
and it's like dick kind of
so his dick will like come out which
horse dicks are wild
oh yes um you could see him from a mile
away i'm like
and they'll come out and then all the
schmeichma will be on it and i'll just
kind of like pick it off really quickly
until he pulls it back in
i'll do like oh my goodness that's first
pass
and then i get so obsessed with it like
i can't stop
and then i'll put my hand up in it i
would say like to hear maybe
jesus what happens if you don't pick the
schmidt
it's just like gets gross and
uncomfortable for them and like
is smelly and you want to keep you want
to take good care i think he's fine it's
more a problem for me
uh i more can't handle it emotionally
wait are you telling me that like
cowboys back in the day because they
were like super close with their horses
and kept good care of them
were they picking shmegma off their
dicks cowboys i
don't know the answer to that but i feel
like cowboys were doing a lot of sketchy
[ __ ] that we'll never know about that's
just so
because you have this image of like
these masculine
frontier men and then at night they're
picking smigma off their horse's [ __ ]
cowboys are pretty i mean there's
something very
uh not masculine about cowboys at the
same time when you look back at like
the super high jeans and they're like
moose knuckles on one side you're like
this is the whole thing's pretty gay
yeah kind of hot like riding horses
yeah brokeback mountain really crack but
it's hot i'm into i do
i think i could totally date a cowboy
that would be good for me probably
yeah i'm not yeah cowboy look but it
could be good for you
could spit you like getting spit in the
mouth you could spit tobacco
chew in your mouth just lasso me
laughter your ass pee on you saddle me
up
all right whitneycummings.com you have a
lot of shows this is exciting
are you is this a good is this good like
are you making good money from this how
is it
in terms of like normal to not it's not
as good as touring normally would be
um uh uh because it's less people and to
put the shows on is so much more
expensive the overhead's so much more
expensive
yeah and it's also really frustrating
because the tickets
to me see are expensive i mean they're
like some of them are 200
because it's per car or per unit because
people
they have to sell it by like groups of
four so that it doesn't encourage people
to
like spread covid so it's like people
so it's like one car you're charged by
car not by person
so it's like if you're paying 200 a car
it's like you know you're gonna have
four people in there and it just like
encourages people to kind of be safer
about it and it's also less people so
it's like the denver shows were only 250
people because that's the max we can do
so i wouldn't we would normally do
theaters that are right you wouldn't
make that much three or five thousand
people yeah it's just less people
yeah but it like i think it's important
to like show that there's a way to do it
safely
and start to just like get the ball kind
of
rolling because we have to just start
figuring out how to solve it and
figuring out
i'm just curious what's going to make
people comfortable like ela if you were
going to go to the staples center like
what would it take for you to walk in
there and go see a lakers game would it
be
like a you walk through like a tsa
screener that like puts red light on you
and you're disinfected is it hand
washing stations is it 15 minute tests
like
we have to start seeing what is going to
work
yeah i feel like right now doing like
staying in your own car is the only way
i could see you'll feel safe i would do
that there was a 15-minute test what if
you to go to a comedy show what if there
was a 15-minute test
no yeah i know those aren't 100 yet it's
not 100
and then all it takes is one dude one
wrong
one wrong positive or negative you know
and um
and that person will spread it to 10
people and then what if you're
what if you go to a comedy show in
inside
and it's distanced and masks
indoors though outdoors i would totally
do that
i think outdoors is fine you know what's
the problem with indoor stuff
is just like with the trump party it's
um the problem is reception
like what happens before and after the
show maybe during the show everyone is
safe but what happens before and after
and
how do you get there about you over here
but i think we have to start seeing like
what yeah
yeah like it's just i think we have to
start letting the business owners like
i think i think if it was outdoors
outdoor with a mask
with a mask i would be pretty
comfortable yeah i would do that that's
what denver shows were like
and it was like everyone was you know
kind of far apart and everyone felt like
good and safe and
but it's about to be winter so right
those are kind of just hang in there i
think one more i think you know
i hate to say it but another year it's
gonna be probably before
some sense of normality for someone like
you
i feel really bad for it for your you
guys have it rough people in your
category you know like
comedians musicians anyone that needs to
tour
it's wrong it's just think music
have it a little better because you can
do like live streaming
music stuff like i mean i don't know why
they're not doing more of it like
the same
that's a good point yeah it feels like
when i've seen like instagram lives with
like
musicians i'm like oh this is like yeah
i never liked being in crowds like i
never liked going to concerts
yeah i don't like going to concerts that
much i [ __ ] hate like
yeah i do too i thought i was the only
weirdo
i hate live music i do i hate it yeah i
think it's awesome
it always it sounds worse than the album
and there's just a bunch of [ __ ]
and you have to stand in lines to go to
the toilet you have to pee in a porta
potty
i would rather just listen to the album
it sounds better and there's nobody
annoying me
can i be such an [ __ ] for a second
i'm sure this didn't get me canceled but
it's about time
i went and saw lauren hill lauren hill's
like my favorite favorite favorite it's
she's obviously very mercurial she
doesn't tour a lot yep
she performed downtown in l.a a couple
years ago
and she's notoriously late
we waited like two hours the dj was
amazing
whatever who cares she comes who [ __ ]
care
i was just like [ __ ] i'll do anything
to see lauryn hill
comes out she sings all the hits
like in 90s reggae like killing me saw
like no one could sing along because
she was differently yeah and it was like
i don't wanna i like she should be able
to do whatever the [ __ ] she wants i
wouldn't want someone
to sing the same song for 20 [ __ ]
years the same way but everyone was so
bummed we're like
we couldn't even participate and i just
was like this is the one
live music experience that i would
[ __ ] go to and it wasn't even
i've had that experience every time i've
gone to live music
i'm just being honest i have to disagree
i think it's so much more fun
and sometimes i love to see when they
put on a whole thing on stage and the
stage is crazy and
um like you're in the majority yeah yeah
i think it's more fun i'm not impressed
it's like oh fireworks
fourth of july seemed better and like
the vibe of everyone together
and i think it depends on the act like
yeah like
when i saw i was in sweden and i went
and saw that band in 1975
live because i love them and their fans
are so like
cool and dorky that it was just like fun
and safe but then
like when you see other bands their fans
are [ __ ] shitty and annoying and dry
like i think it depends on the
artist and the kind of fans they have
too yeah
like if they have shitty annoying like
kid rocks fans you probably thought
now we're talking i used to think he was
really hot i still think he's coming out
d really well you might have a chance
with him he's like dirty
what does he look like i think he is
like incurable stds though because he
was with pam
anderson you don't know
here tell me if you're [ __ ] wrong
i've had the
no hepatitis yeah he's got like he's got
like hep
oh no that's your type no no there's
something just
hot about that's not my type but he's
like
bro look at kid rock he does trump
rallies and [ __ ] he's like
you know how they joke about how how
trump has all these shitty celebs that
endorse him good rock
is uh and scott baio and antonio sabato
junior
did you see the true [ __ ] rock ela i
don't like it
look rate them on one to ten
like he looks like white like one and a
half one and a half
you should hear his music elo his first
his sweet home alabama rendition is good
and daryl
song called picture is good and i stand
by that
and your fans are going to unfollow me
i'm standing my ground i'm a hater
everyone knows i'm a hater
what do you listen to who's your
favorite singer
he listens to i don't know i like
hip-hop yeah i like
uh are you like a run the jewels guy no
no no
i like the more newer stuff like but not
a lot i don't listen to music that much
i'm gonna be straight up [ __ ] honest
with you
i don't ever listen to music around my
house like i listen to music more i
don't know what happened
we're just busy like i i can't really
work and listen to music
yeah i mean it's distracting but i'm
very curious like if you're doing a road
trip like what are you listening to
i would put on a lot of motown a lot of
motown
uh or i like paul simon
i like the beatles i like
um
the oldest conversation i've ever had
that's it that's what you asked and
that's what it is
i appreciate your honesty i appreciate
you not trying to be cool
paul simon is awesome i don't know paul
said how old are you
you don't know no i know how old i just
i haven't listened to his music
yeah it's old still crazy
after all yeah you know that song's a
banger it's not even
richard mark cause like i know like you
were talking about morrison
i like van morrison i like being
morrison
my horse's [ __ ] too van morrison
[Laughter]
ew what was your wedding song
uh well we had like a whole playlist
that we put together
it was a lot of he released that to the
public oh
the song that we walked to what was it
it was it was a uh
well there was two there was a dude
looked like a lady
yeah it was uh the persuasions which is
all the um
yeah the person dua band and they did a
cover of a frank zappa song called uh
uh [ __ ] i don't even remember star in
the sky or what is it
and then when we when we when i stomped
on the glass we played um uh
what was that why am i blanking yeah
this
is really are you guys really married
well it's been a while it was great
choices is this a hoax
what was it it was a relationship yeah
this is like when people pretend they're
married to good citizenship
she's already a citizen so you can't
help us i'm just i'm just saying it's
like
are you going to report us to uci i feel
like those what if it's revealed in this
college there and i can't remember well
they were super obscure and
i really liked them at the time that's
the issue that we're having with me
i think you actually renew your vows oh
interesting that could be fun that could
be fun because we never did anything
here
oh the wedding was in israel i don't
want to do the whole aisle though but
isn't it douchey like
yeah doesn't it seem kind of like look
at me
like to having more podcasts isn't it
um yeah just like what do i got to read
like i'm good
we're good i feel like it's from
seinfeld
they're like if you don't have anything
bad to share about your relationship no
one wants to hear it
science this is why we get along so well
i
broke off an engagement i was like i
don't get getting married like it's
embarrassing i don't want to
i'm actually really shy when i'm not
doing what we do
like i just like the idea of people
looking at me and giving a serious
speech just like it
like seems why would i be bombing for my
comedian friends on a saturday
for free so you broke off your marriage
because you didn't like the idea of a
wedding
i just i'm sure if it was the maybe the
right person
i'd be super into it you know but i just
got i
i felt embarrassed like what ela just
said about like doesn't it feel like i'm
drawing attention to myself it's like
how much attention do i need like i had
shame come up
that ended your relationship it ended
yeah
yeah because he's like well why don't
you want to marry me he was like well it
doesn't seem like you want to get
married i was like i just i don't i was
having a hard time wrapping my head
around the wedding thing
and i just needed more time to figure
out a way to do a wedding that didn't
make me feel like ashamed and like
it's very weird like yeah i feel like
even at the time it was super weird for
me and we were kind of forced to do it
because in israel you have to like the
family
david my family forced us to have a big
wedding and do the whole thing because
otherwise it's disrespectful
so like we wanted to do a small thing
and they were like
no it's not happening her dad had this
great move where he um
we were doing test tasting yeah and he
cruises in and he's like
this food is embarrassing we have to get
the more expensive [ __ ]
and but he didn't pay for it we were
paying we were like
we were like students yeah he we had no
nothing for it you know we just and we
are paying for the wedding
and he's like you gotta get the best
food you gotta invite everyone
you gotta have the best alcohol
it cannot be embarrassing it cannot be
an embarrassing wedding do you have to
plan it all
yeah it took months it was like it was
fun though
i mean it was a really fun evening it
was like a big party and
it was like 200 people for ela five
people for me
yeah jesus that's a small wedding in
israel yeah it's small
people do like four or five hundred
seven hundred
know these people i don't think i should
know them do they either i don't know
all of them it's it's like
well i have a really big family so once
you start inviting all the family and
the cousins
and then um my mom's work people my
dad's
work people like everyone's got a car
wow
it's like open it's like a it's like a
rally so that was just ila's side 200.
because it was in israel i just got like
overwhelmed and i think it's also we
do so much logistics it's like by the
time that i was like oh i feel like i'm
making a tv show i'm making a production
but it's costing me money i'm like
that's usually
i usually make money doing this thing so
it's weird but do you think that
you wanted to break up with him and
that's kind of why
you didn't like the wedding idea i think
when the rubber hits the road when
you're like
do i want to when you're like oh yeah i
would totally spend the rest of my life
this person and then you're like
here's the check the amount of money
it'll cost to have the ceremony do it
you're like
if you're not willing to i mean like
when it gets down to like contracts and
legal stuff it just [ __ ] it gets more
real are you richer than he was
by a lot i don't know we never like i
never was like how much exactly do you
have
really i feel like i would know that if
i was ready to marry someone i want to
know everything about them
you said you're like ela how much cash
do you have yeah we were already sharing
a bank oh we were
but we didn't have one we met when we
had nothing we were broke as a [ __ ]
and then oh dude you helped me pay off
my student debt
yeah that's so [ __ ] but so when i
came
when i moved here before we were married
when i moved here i brought everything i
had which was like three thousand
dollars
so that was like everything i had i
bought that and we put it together in
our bank and that was it
since then we share a bank when we moved
to israel before we were married i had
like
i don't know 25 30 thousand dollars in
student debt and he
helped me pay it down before we got
married
have you ever had big disagreements
about money like is there ever like a
you can't buy that
no always on the same wavelength with
money
ethan is always like he's actually
always been like oh if you want to get
that you know like
but because we're really responsible
before we had a lot of money like i
wanted this expensive marker set and he
was like oh you should get it
you know like so it was always like kind
of supportive in that way but we where
are
we very responsible like because there's
other there's people like trisha paytas
who will go yeah seventy thousand
dollars on a handbag but we were never
doing
it there was never a problem it was
never like dude we don't have money
you know right right right right yeah
what a good one though huh can you
believe this
the best i'm obsessed with i said i paid
off my whole student debt before we
even got married
you ever fight
um
[Music]
like what's the last fight you had i
feel like now it's not really i feel
like we
we're mostly just after the baby so it's
like did you wake up i
need to wake up it's your turn it's not
really fights though it's just kind of
like
it's survival we're just like
we have this baby and he needs to be
happy
fed sleep you know like we're just
always around that and two dogs by the
way and two
we're really needy little [ __ ] too
but the
the truth is i don't think i think we're
just both super exhausted right now so
it's like ela said just
just survival we're overworked right now
too
yeah it's our animal it's
our anniversary and this saturday
what are you gonna do how many years
eight years married
what are you gonna do i'm really
thinking about amy
for sure you know you know for sure
i'm gonna i was thinking about being on
her maybe
we were just thinking of going to a nice
hotel and did and leaving the baby with
with my parents i have some ideas
you do really we can what
why leave the baby with me oh [ __ ] no
[Laughter]
me and my robot will raise it i'll never
leave my bait with the horse lady
why does her baby have an eye infection
um
i have some ideas of hotels cool i'd
love to hear because we're not
yeah we don't know i heard of one in
laguna beach that someone recommended me
and
honestly that sounds nice but i don't
know anything about it
i look you probably have better ideas
than yeah
you're bougier you're bougier than
gorgeous hotels
no i've just had i've gone to lots of
nice hotels to try to save failing
relationships
i call them last resort it's the last
resort
oh my god
and then when you're like i feel like
that's a reality show
right there
where people are just like and then when
you're paying a lot of money for a room
that's when the rubber hits the road
you're like yeah [ __ ] this person i'm
out like you're
not you're gonna do this now here
like if we still hate each other in a
hut in thailand we hate each other
right so i'm kind of surprised by how
expensive these hotels get because i
never really stayed in like these really
high level [ __ ] like the one we were
looking at in laguna beach was like 3
000 a night
that sounds crazy but i was like i was
like oh bro
it looks like just a hotel it's called
um
do you remember the name the inn or no
no
oh it's is it the one with the sun in
the pool the pool is like a sun
it just looks like a big hotel it
honestly yeah it didn't look that
[ __ ] extraordinary
yeah it was like 3 000 a night it might
even be good to just get like a really
nice airbnb for a couple nights
i don't like staying in other people's
houses we had a really traumatic
experience
when we moved here from israel we were
so
we were moving back here we're so
exhausted
we stayed she was probably a horse lady
if i'm being honest
looking back i don't think so i think
horse ladies actually have their [ __ ]
together
she was like maybe she was a mess she no
horse ladies
they take care of themselves okay good
this was that was this was like the
early days of airbnb when it was still a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] show i mean now they want to type
it was such a nightmare we got here at
like 3 a.m or something
after maybe spending 30 hours just
getting here because we had a
layover in the flight because you know
anyway and we had we brought everything
with us so we had a bunch of luggage and
um we told our friends don't worry about
it we got it we're gonna go to airbnb so
no one was picking us up we just took a
taxi
to the airbnb and we got there and it
was like
a homeless shack i don't know what the
quality because it was expensive you
know it looked expensive but there was
like mold in the shower like all over
the wall
there were like beds everywhere and it
looked like
i don't know it was weird like the
living room had beds everywhere like
they're ready for i don't know what yeah
i mean it looked like a hostel
now we thought we were getting the whole
house we thought we were getting the
whole house
there was a lady she was there she was
there there she was sleeping in another
room no the whole thing was so s
so we walk in there's mold everywhere it
smells like cigarettes
and there's a lady in there there's like
other people in there i was like well no
[ __ ]
yeah and we were like okay well we
cannot stay here it's 4 00 a.m
we just got to the states and we're like
okay let's
try to wake up our friends and we
luckily our friend
isaac came and got us then we got on
dispute with her because you're trying
to get a
there's some like amazing houses in like
malibu you can rent for like a couple
nights that are like
they're like airbnb pros like these
really really yeah
yeah yeah i'll send you some links tim
dillon and i were looking because we
were quarantine lovers and we were like
looking for like places to go like stay
together and
that sounds really fun actually yeah it
works yeah we were like he was my
quarantine buddy he's been with me most
of the time so it's been like
super fun has he peed on you he hasn't
peed on me
i mean i'd be fine with it um he's
coming on our show soon i'll ask him
about it
oh i'm sorry dude he's the [ __ ]
funniest he's so funny yeah
yeah it's like we i spend the entire
quarantine learning about like
uh adrinochrome and hollywood eating
baby dicks and
you know oh god it's been a weird person
to spend six months with non-stop
but he's the [ __ ] best i think you'll
like him you haven't met him before
no yeah tim is like he makes me laugh
[ __ ] he's like one of the only people
i'm really good friends with and i
listen to his podcast like as a fan
he just seems like a super funny dude
yeah he's like one of the few comics
right now that like
has the balls like just with this like
cancel culture no one can say anything
like he just [ __ ]
it's helped him so much like cancel
culture is actually helping comedians in
a lot of ways
because it's just making more things be
off limits and that's what we do is we
just [ __ ] say [ __ ] you're not
supposed to say
so what pc canceled culture doesn't know
they're doing is they're just helping us
and tim is like a great example of that
it's awesome good for him yeah just
don't make fun of k-pop
trust me don't touch k-pop
it doesn't go well trust me
by the way don't make fun of west
virginia
or detroit oh really either
they'll come for you yeah uh there's
like a couple cities that their pride is
like
so intense that it's just like not it's
like dangerous
florida's fine text this is fine like
they're fine with it they're used to it
but there's a couple places that have
are like randomly like oh [ __ ] that's
awesome
two hundred thousand followers
that's awesome
do not [ __ ] with west virginia or
detroit
[Laughter]
um whitneycummings.com
well i hope you have a wish you lots of
success on the tour and i hope it's fun
and good and
lots of honking of course
[Laughter]
what used to be cat calling is now
even worse yeah just like how we receive
adulation
and what i love you guys love you so
much um
keep up all the different things you're
doing it's fun following you
on instagram you talk about this like i
feel like i'm having a mental breakdown
publicly
yeah like i feel like this is my spiral
and you're now um an accomplice
but it's like pandemic time so we're all
kind of having
meltdowns so you for the time it's
perfect time
to tell me if i seem insane and like
unwell
okay okay i will i mean the
the pink hair was like i told you it was
a little bit of a oh you gave her a
warning about the picture i was
i was just like coming from youtube it
reminds me of like
youtubers red hair green hair blue hair
yeah she was like are you okay
you said that okay i was kind of joking
when i kind of said
it
how are you doing girl you want to go
for a walk like everything okay
you're 38 and you just dyed your hair
bang like what's that well there you go
so we all need friends like elo
do you have a miscarriage she asked me
that every day she's like you're okay
dude like you know what i'm talking you
know when you watch someone on social
media on instagram stories and
and then you're like they go off the
rails and yeah you're not doing that
no i'm doing that there's people on
youtube who goes off the [ __ ]
rails you're just having fun there's
people who are like out there ruining
their lives for real
don't let me be like the hey guys so
guys
guys if i'm ever the hey guys person
please
shoot me in the face okay you have my
god i'm so thirsty guys i'll just wait
you'll
wake up one night and i'll be like you
told me to do this
gun in your face no warning you told me
to do this
[ __ ] let me wipe the p off my face so
you can shoot me
um yeah please do it intervention
because i feel like i said it because
you
you men you i think you were asking me i
didn't just say to make you feel bad or
anything like this out of character that
you know i
promise you i think you mentioned
something that you felt like maybe you
were starting to go too far because like
i think it was 9 11 and you didn't
notice
right
so i was like i'm gonna i'm too addicted
to social media i'm gonna do less
instagram i'm only gonna post and get
off i'm not gonna mindlessly scroll
so there was like i had um for my
birthday we did a covid tested like hang
out at my house it was like five girls
we did like piercings
and my friends comedian esther taught us
the wet ass [ __ ] dance
where you like [ __ ] the floor yeah and
i posted it and was like all right
that's gonna be hilarious like whatever
that's kind of out of character for me
to post like an ass
thing and then i go back and i realized
i had posted it on 9 11.
and everyone's posts were like never
forget never forget and then it was just
like wet ass
[Laughter]
i did some [ __ ] with like like my boobs
or something like super out of character
like sexual post
and i went back and it was ruth later
against bergen
that's awesome next time i see like a
weirdly
sexual post i'll check the news and see
if that's right
like not reading the room at all
like just here's my [ __ ] everyone's
like black box black square black square
black
but uh but yeah i just you we i feel
like during the pandemic i've definitely
lost a couple like it does kind of ruin
friendships when
you see someone lose their mind on
instagram you can never see them the
same way
yeah you haven't lost your mind yeah no
just like you lose respect for someone
we're not there yet don't let me go
there don't let me hey guys my
way into not being friends with you
anymore
i love our new friendship villa because
i can ask you something and you tell me
the truth
yes no yeah no ask me anything
i uh sometimes i worry that i do that
too
like i'm too honest with uh like i do
that to christina and tom too
tell them i complained about the
lighting on their set
you don't like the lighting on their set
is that it's too dark i want to see
their faces i mean it does look like
anne frank's attic
maybe that's the vibe they're going for
it is a hovel it is a hovel
i know i went on there i was like why do
i look like steve buscemi
why do i look like [ __ ]
but yeah they do keep it very dark yeah
i feel like didn't think about that i
think you're right we need to survive
yeah we need to have a uh intervention
it looks like their set looks like that
airbnb you stayed at it
this mattress is
i love you guys love you thank you for
joining us
god bless thank you for joining us
news.com
and uh it's good for you i feel insecure
coming on your show but your fans are
super nice what
why you're superstars when you go on
someone's show that has like a really
big show and you're like an outsider
coming in
no we're just oh i think everyone loves
you yeah yeah
you're a friend of the show alumni what
oh can i ask you one howard stern
question
sure i'm um you're a big howard fan yeah
right they just asked me to come on and
do something
and i don't know it as well as you do
gary
asked me to gary
how do you spell that same deliberation
we notice that bigfoot never laughs we
want to put you on the phone with him
for three minutes awesome yeah they
try to make him laugh do you know who
bigfoot is
no he's part of the whack pack he's like
this total [ __ ]
he's like he's just such a weirdo he's
like super tall
crackhead [ __ ] he's got like a 20
incher apparently
yeah delusional right that's the guy
that because i think he recently
played and he was like uh yeah the
government is chasing me right now
oh maybe yeah but no you should
definitely do that
you should do you think i'd be able to
make him laugh probably not
but i think it would be funny
you have to do it it'll be so fun
regardless i mean everyone else will
laugh
you know he's dull the thing is he's
dull
okay so he's not he's not gonna
necessarily understand
your jokes yeah i mean i'm not
i can't like just do stand up yeah
you're gonna have to get inside the mind
of
madness i think to make it i don't even
know what how to make so you know
i'd love to listen to that though i
would listen to that so i think you
should totally do that you're good
they're just bombing for bigfoot i mean
yeah that's gonna be better than doing
stand up for cars and parking lots
i wouldn't know how to approach that
personally it's definitely a
interesting definitely interesting
you were the person i was waiting to
talk to about it you should do that was
zac's a fan of howard too zach do you
have any advice for making
bigfoot laugh um
yeah so he lives in vermont and he's
very attracted to things in that area
so yeah actually
what is that yeah
he loves his surroundings and i mean he
lives in a trailer and
yeah okay
was that helpful whitney no
yeah i'm actually less prepared
i feel like i know less after asking you
he's infatuated with his home that's
what my point yeah
okay okay i don't think you'll succeed
but it'll be fun
i don't think anybody will i don't think
anyone could yeah no but you got to do
it
you have to do it all right i'll let you
know i let you know
i was on the fence and you're you're
encouraging me now i might do it well
what are you afraid of that you'll bomb
i think there's no losing yeah if if you
bomb it's funny
too because yeah that's true i think
there's a little bit of a like
howard is howard and you you know i'm
like you're really more trying to
impress howard
yes right like i'd rather
instead of having all his fans think
it's funny i'd rather
him you just when you get in there with
him it's all about his approval you just
like
time travel and you turn into like a
five-year-old just trying to get your
dad to pay attention to you like it's
just you progress
it's not necessarily a pleasant
experience you think it's stressful
well yeah because it's like you just
like it's how you just want him to go
you don't want him to go like oh that
was a disaster no he wouldn't do that
yeah but you know him i don't yeah i do
he's like a friend too which makes it a
little embarrassing
just like [ __ ] you gary bubba
[Laughter]
no i think i'll do i i just like to know
how something's going to go
you're going to be like
i'll tell you right now that is actually
kind of liberating just like i'm going
to bomb
it yeah see that's actually the best
advice you can give if you were like
you're gonna kill i'd be like i can't do
this no you're gonna
think you've got a bomb we already know
it's gonna suck now just go have fun and
be an idiot
yeah yes that's that amazing approach
that's the approach that's
nothing to lose yeah really yeah you
have nothing to lose
yeah okay i love you guys
all right take care thanks for calling
thank you friends i hope that was good
no can't wait for all the dick pics some
of your dick pics everyone
let's get them got there even rates them
for free that's a premium service
i'm lonely all right bye whitney
[Music]
bye